una recta secante se intersecta con la
curva que iguala la tangente de x
en dos puntos cuyas coordenadas en la
variable x son pi cuartos y t ok escribe
una expresión de m
como función de tema que te dé la
pendiente de la recta secante
sabemos que tenemos dos puntos dentro de
esta recta secante podría tal vez no ser
tan obvio en un principio por la manera
en la que lo escribieron pero hagamos
una tabla para que veas todo mucho más
claro y entiendas cuáles son mis dos
puntos a los que me refiero voy a hacer
por aquí una pequeña tabla ok por aquí
me voy a tomar el valor de x y por aquí
me voy a tomar el valor de fx que bueno
nos dicen que es la curva
james igual la tangente de x así que voy
a poner que fx es igual ahí muy bien
ahora sabemos qué pasa cuando tenemos x
igual a pi cuartos déjame escribirlo x
igual a pi cuartos qué valor toma y
bueno pues habría que evaluar en esta
función de aquí me quedaría la tangente
la tangente
y cuartos y cuartos y bueno cuantos la
tangente de pi cuartos eso es la
tangente de 45 grados y es igual a 1
estás de acuerdo
aquí me quedaría simplemente 1 y ahora
qué pasa si pongo el valor de tema
si x valete entonces quién es
efe tm la función evaluada ante bueno
simplemente me quedaría la tangente la
tangente de de ok la tangente dt
diagramó observa tenemos dos puntos
tenemos primero el punto de gm
escribirlo aquí el punto pi cuartos y
cuartos
como tangente de pi cuartos que quedamos
que era 1 ok y también tengo otro punto
tengo el punto y coma la tangente de t
como la tangente dt que es lo que vale
la función ente y si tengo dos puntos
por lo tanto puedo sacar la pendiente de
esta recta secante porque recuerda que
la pendiente es simplemente el cambio y
james entre el cambio en x así que esto
me quedaría igual a quien bueno pues me
va a quedar igual al cambio en game
quien sería nuestro cambio in game bueno
si me tomo a éste como el punto final
voy a tomarme a esto como el punto final
me quedaría la tangente la tangente
dt ok y ahora le voy a quitar el otro
valor que tomamos en quien que es una
tangente de t menos 1 ya esto lo voy a
dividir entre el cambio en x quien es el
cambio en x bueno si esté a nuestro
punto final nuestro cambio en x va a ser
- y aquí tengo el otro valor de x que es
cuartos menos
cuartos y qué creés hemos terminado esta
es la solución de este problema tangente
dt déjame escribirlo tangente dtm menos
uno esto a su vez dividido entre de
menos pi cuartos y bueno observa que
está pendiente es una función de tema
eso es muy importante porque es justo lo
que nos piden escriben una expresión de
m como función de tema y aquí es justo
lo que tengo tengo a m como función de t
y una vez más solamente tuvimos que
pensar que la recta secante contenía dos
puntos que tal vez siendo un principio
no eran tan obvios pero después de hacer
esta tabla
vimos que tenemos los puntos y cuartos
coma tangente de pi cuartos tanque entre
45 grados que es uno y el segundo punto
eran tecomán ft y bueno tal vez aquí no
decía que la función era f
y yo le puse ese nombre pero creo que se
entiende bastante bien todo lo que
acabamos de hacer una vez que tenemos
estos dos puntos entonces encontramos
una manera muy sencilla la pendiente
entre ellos dos